all right everybody
looks like where
on track to begin so I'm gonna start
um forgive me if I sort of look a bit
blinded when I look up to those of you
folks at the back there are a couple of
big lights and they shine in my eyes I
should really have worn some uh very
dark sunglasses or whatever to be able
to see you at the back
um hopefully you are here to see me Ian
Cooper talk about
um uh at least once so at least once is
really asking the question
what happens in a world where we can't
use two-phase commit uh to talk between
two databases
who am I
um I'm old that's what that most of that
says
um I always try and highlight the bottom
point which is you know I'm I'm here
only because I ended up getting speaking
at local user groups we didn't have
anybody
um and anyway got me into conferences
and then that got me speaking on the
stage and I'm not smart than any of you
are I just had the right opportunities
and and you can certainly do what I'm
doing and please do think about speaking
it's great for helping you organize your
thoughts and helping your work to
present ideas
what are we going to talk about today
um so we're going to talk about an idea
called fiefdoms from Pat Helen along
with collaborations another idea from
Pat Helen and emissaries you'll see down
there on point number four
we'll talk about where those ideas come
from and how they relate to things you
may have heard of more recently because
they're slightly older ideas
we'll talk a little bit about messaging
how that works in terms of what we think
about as future and past and how we do
stuff in a way that's transactionally
consistent
um we'll come across some ideas like
resources and activities and at the end
I'll show you a little bit of some code
for how we can kind of try and Implement
some of those ideas uh using an open
source project I work on called brighter
okay
so in 2007 uh Pat Helen uh he's a
architect that's worked variously at
Microsoft and Amazon and some of the
things he's responsible for include
msdtc which is a distributed transaction
coordinator in the Microsoft space and
he wrote one of the original papers that
led to
dynamodb coming to existence which
influences things like Cassandra and
Cosmos so perhaps reasonably
competent uh
fella and Pat essentially his name and
career had been associated with
two-phase commit and in 2007 he wrote a
paper which essentially said you know
what two-phase commit is not the right
solution in distributed systems
and his point was kind of two-fold and
we'll dig into a lot of it later
um one is that most of us don't actually
do TPC most developers do something else
entirely and a little bit it's kind of
recognizing the reality of our space and
quite often he didn't have a distributed
transaction coordinator which worked
over all the things you were trying to
use in other cases devs just simply
found other ways around it
um but also Pat was looking at a number
of other ideas in this article one of
them is probably the one we'll focus on
today is service oriented architectures
which are really a precursor to
microservices
the other is he looked at some ideas for
how you could create
um uh infinite scale data storage and
that's really the ideas that lead to
things like Dynamo well we won't really
talk about that part of the idea today
because unless you're using Dynamo or
Cosmos it's less relevant to you
and Pat also talked a little bit about
the idea of saying that your application
code should be scalognostic and we
should sit over some kind of invisible
platform layer that effectively deals
with scaling and a little bit those
ideas today come from serverless
platforms or kubernetes and Pat was
really a little bit ahead of his time
the other thing we'll talk about don't
worry about reading the text I just
didn't it doesn't have like a magazine
image I can give you so that's just the
image from Pat's blog in 2020 Pat Uh
released another paper called autonomous
computing
and autonomous Computing is really an
update of some of the ideas in life
beyond distributed transactions and it
brings in some things around fiefdoms
um and emissaries that he hadn't really
previously tied into his other work but
he had spoken about in the early
noughties quite a lot of conferences and
ties that all together with his stuff on
distributed transactions Etc so
um this talk will cover both because I
want to basically make sure you're
getting the kind of more current version
of what Pat was talking about
just out of interest for anyone who
doesn't really understand what we're
saying when we say two-phase commit or
TPC occasionally
so if I have two databases that are
essentially remote from each other right
it could be I want to say database it
could be a cluster as well as being a
database
if I want them to both participate in a
transaction so a typical example might
be customer makes an order and I want to
update the amount of stock we have
something on hand right
if I want to do that across two
databases let's imagine that I have a
database that serves my stock management
system be it a microservice or whatever
and a database that serves basically
getting customer orders in
effectively I'd want to take a lock in
both systems a lock effectively as I
write the New Order and unlock as I
decrement about the amount of stock that
I have of something
and the way you do that in two-phase
commit is you have a coordinator and the
coordinator sends a message to both
databases saying hey can I lock that
right can I lock that information
and then the individual databases vote
and they say yep you can do that or no
usually somebody else has got it locked
you can't do that
and then as a result of that vote
the coordinator says okay we can either
commit
or essentially those of you that have
reserved that lot for me in our
participation of my doing something can
release it
and if everyone agrees then we write the
data
DTC has a performance penalty to us as
I'm sure you can imagine right because
effectively the coordinator has to do
this kind of double question
so the question Pat wanted to ask and as
a person you know who who had spent
their career in in uh two-phase commit
is what happens if we throw that away
what happens if we say that's not
available to you
all right so let's talk about fief terms
one of uh Pat's first ideas
so a fiefdom
those pink boxes
pink hexagons in fact
um uh encapsulate their data and they
say hey nobody else can take a lock on
my data it belongs to me and to nobody
else
and they have an explicit boundary
anything outside that boundary can't
reach in and take locks on the data
inside that boundary
and because of that we tend to think of
the thing inside the boundary as inside
data
and we expose some kind of API we're not
going to get into what that is just at
this point
where effectively you can say well you
can send me messages and I will update
the state of that data inside
we also don't want to try and do some
kind of join
to this data over HTTP or grpc or some
other kind of RPC connection so we don't
expose what you might want to think of
as a get endpoint to just grab our data
instead what we do is we publish a
stream of events usually some kind of
syndicated stream which gives you facts
we're willing to share about data inside
and that shared streamers of what we
call outside data outside data has some
properties right
it's immutable in other words it's a
read-only thing that I've given you you
can't there's no point in you changing
it the only way to change it is to send
me a message on my API I update the
inside data I issue some new outside
data
and you store it and you tend to call it
reference data right
where essentially because the notion is
typically you're using for reference so
for example my current job is working
for justic takeaway we effectively
service
like you order from restaurants
what we tend to do is publish the menu
and restaurant details so that other
services or uis can read that data and
you just present options to you you
don't do a get
from your UI to say hey let's get the
menu from the restaurant from the
service hey it's particularly slow right
if you basically put it in a what we
call a forward cache you can essentially
put it on cloudfront distribute it and
get it from a from your phone or your
web browser
so we don't want to do anything that
essentially says I'm reaching in to get
hold of your data and we don't want to
do get either
there's other little fancy things on the
diagram
so this set of messages that we send
back and forth as we interact with a
victim
Pat thinks them as a collaboration
when you hear collaboration you should
think about dialogue conversation or
workflow again we'll dig into more
detail on what it is in a little bit
and that little little stick figure
that's an emissary
it's an emissary helps you use the API
that is provided by a fiefdom
a really simple example of an emissary
is a user interface
and then you can see from this diagram
that while you might have originally
thought oh feast and that's just a micro
service right Ian
the reality is of fiefdom can a
microservice is a fiefdom but other
things are fiefdoms
so the app running on your phone is a
fiefdom
the app running in your user agent your
browser is also a fiefdom right
piston which contains other victims if
you want to have boundaries that
represent for example organizational and
departmental boundaries uh effectively
you can invoke Conway's law and declare
that a feat them and say there's stuff
inside and stuff outside right this talk
is less about that last option but we're
more looking at the other pieces here
that we're getting into
okay
all right
so we'll start off talking about this
idea of collaborations
so I have a fiefdom victim a on it's the
right hand side as I look at it it's the
right hand side for D2
and I want to do some work right
something stimulates that work I
probably receive a request from outside
there might be a timer event I might
receive a message
and as part of that work I'm I'm doing
some work in my domain and I realize I
don't have responsibility for that
somebody else does so my typical example
here is I am effectively part of my
assistant the system that essentially
processes purchases for us I do some
validation I check the prices I apply
some discounts Etc and I may have to
call it other services right I might
have to call another service to figure
out what are the offers that apply to
this I may have to call another service
or another feature in this case to say
well what are the what's the delivery
fees for this I'm about to call another
fiefdom and say hey can you take a
payment for this for me
so I may not be doing all of the work
and at some point I need to call
somebody else to do their part of the
work
so at some point I will wait
and I will transfer control to another
fiefdom
I'll say you have control now of this
workflow
and this interaction tends to result in
a reply to me saying okay I I've given
you control you go and do your work and
you give me a response back here are the
delivery fees here is the discounts here
is the customer has paid and that is
accepted right
so this dialogue is kind of ongoing when
fiefdoms talk to each other
but this is uncertain
because the other fiefdom
might say
our customer didn't actually manage to
take pay for that their car was declined
or we might say hey we don't deliver to
that uh that space that's too far out of
range
or we might say
um hey those prices don't look right to
me
I don't know where the customer got them
from maybe somebody's trying to
basically fool Us by uh you know hacking
basically the front end to put in their
own prices and see what happens
so there can be failures
well not failures but there can be paths
basically other than the happy path
and so Pat says in a system that cannot
count on distributed transactions the
management of uncertainty must be
implemented in the business logic
in other words when we don't have TPC
when we're not locking everything we're
locking delivery fees and everything
else basically what we end up doing is
having these conversations
and it's all logic it's application code
that replaces TPC
and in a sense what Pat's saying is he's
recognizing that that's actually the way
that most people build systems
they don't use two phase commit they
write some code that eventually called
other code so what does that mean if we
do that right what do we mean if we take
that approach
so
some coffee shops when you go to them
they have a cashier
and they have a barista who's going to
make the coffee
and in these coffee shops cost a coffee
mentioning no names what happens is that
uh I go up and I ask to pay
order my coffee
and either in some cases whether I
understaffed the cashier or is actually
the Barista guys it makes the coffee or
they talk to their friend who's the
Barista and they make the coffee
and essentially I stand there waiting
blocking the whole queue
until my work is done I get the coffee
back
and I can go and sit down
and a queue
will build up behind me
the constraint becomes really as fast as
this Barista can work everyone will keep
and if you go into one of these coffee
shops eventually no names cost a coffee
people you'll see people walk out the
back of the queue
even in the United Kingdom where as you
all know we love queuing
and we have our own special cue which
recently appeared on on television the
height of britishness the best queue
ever
um
people joined it not because they like
the royal family but because they liked
the idea of joining the world's greatest
queue
um
even though we love queuing obviously it
gets frustrating in the morning when
you're trying to get somewhere you
haven't got time to wait Etc so you tend
to give up right
so Starbucks doesn't do that
in Starbucks what happens I think they
actually have some kind of like you know
potent on this model or whatever so it's
not about what happens they go up to the
cashier and I say oh can I order a
coffee and she writes basically the
details of my coffee on a cup
it's an important thing she asked me for
my name
we'll come back to where that is in a
little bit
and she essentially cues those cups for
the Barista so basically we just create
a task queue same kind of thing you
would do if you used a task you pattern
right
she puts those in a queue and the
barista
just comes and takes them off Services
them and gives them to the customers
so the constraint now becomes really how
many Baristas do we have how many
espresso machines do we have that's
about as fast as we can work right and
then you tend to find the number depends
on how much they think you know the
throughput is going to be in that shop
now I still have to wait but generally
speaking I'm prepared to wait once I've
ordered my coffee uh because I can
something else check my phone or I've
actually my coffee turns up right
but this queuing strategy
is one we see a lot
in software
what do they ask for your name because
it's a correlation ID right same thing
we do in messaging I send out a request
I wait for a reply to my request
how do I know that reply what request it
was for generally call it correlation ID
they don't care in Starbucks if you go
in and when when you say what's your
name you say Spartacus so that when
basically the hand over a coffee for
Spartacus you can do the I'm Spartacus
gag they don't care right well you can
call yourself anything I wouldn't try
calling yourself a good because it's
going to be hard for them to write down
um but they just want to correlate
messages is that the same thing we do in
messaging right
um by the way if you don't know how to
build this kind of thing uh because
sometimes I get this with apis if your
front end wants to say hey I've got your
order I'm putting on a queue it's going
to go to the back end and the back end
effectively will pull them off and do
the work as it needs here's how you do
it you basically need to rely on https
202 accepted
to what to accept it says I've got your
order I've got your your post request or
whatever I ain't gonna give you an
answer right now but I got it
which lets the person that's the UI Etc
go okay and move on with something else
what you do is
a cadda
you give a URI usually to something you
can poll to find out the status of your
your work
so you just say okay great I'll poll
that and when it's done
I can essentially tell my users
effectively the work is now complete
um and they can go and do whatever they
need to do right
right um You can also use a push
notification so in the link here you
simply say actually you're going to get
a push notification over here sockets
that kind of thing right
right but that way you effectively say
when I get that request in I just put it
on a queue I can then my web server will
get to it at some point and I'll give
you back and usually we refer to what we
call a task oriented UI where the user
goes in does a whole load of work to
basically make selections to use their
coffee choose the options everything
else that they need and then they press
the magic button right and they expect
when they press the magic button to have
to wait
um they only want really that Speed and
Performance when they're making
selection choices
so what we do between fiefdoms is we use
messaging
we don't use synchross communication
between feed terms which implies holding
open a transaction for a response to
update multiple entities we use
messaging
overall Pat's perspective
the HTTP these are not the things you
want to use between victims right you
want to use some kind of messaging
solution
now you can title messaging over you
know TCP IP https that's not what he's
talking about
um but he's saying you have to send
something that is kind of like hey I'm
going to send you something like to your
reply
okay so looking at my
fiefdom on the right hand side of
Houston a
you can see that I've started some work
at some point what happens is I need to
say okay I need to hand over work the
work is right just for application code
which is effectively guiding this
particular thing that I need to do
probably what happened is I got
stimulated
by a request or a message or some timer
to begin some work so the work begins
and I need to hand over to another
fiefdom
at that point I'm going to have to store
some state
because I now have an operation which
effectively I'm going to stop
while I wait for a response from the
other victim and I probably need to
preserve some state to say Here's Where
I Was Here with a state of things when
basically I gave up
and then essentially send a message
I can go on and 50 million do other work
Ed and B responds to that
picks up the message does its work and
puts a reply back to me
and I received a reply and I get on with
the rest of my work right so payment you
can think of I need a payment
I suspend basically working on that
order I put it in some state to put a
you know put an enum on it for a state
machine saying hey this order is pending
payment
say that in my database and then
eventually I send a message to other
systems saying hey can you take payment
for it
eventually it replies I get that message
in and I say hey I got a payment there's
a correlation ID I will look that up
okay that order is I can now Move Along
its state
so Pat talks about these things being
activities there's State machines that
tracked incoming collaboration and a
sequence of messages
this activity which is essentially your
code plus some state
can do things like well
um hey I didn't get a response back on
this one what I'm doing is looking at
things that are in the pending State and
this has been in pending state for more
than a certain amount of time maybe I
will alert an operator maybe I will
resend that particular request maybe it
got lost somewhere Etc right
so activities become the things that
give you reliability
and reliability is not just simply about
hey retry the operation that failed or
something
um
but uh
as I say maybe actively monitoring these
activities that you have in progress
so as a result of that what tends to
happen is that any one of our fiefdoms
our activity tends to store this concept
of I have sent a message I have received
a message
and essentially this message history if
you like
becomes effectively the history of our
interaction with other fiefdoms via that
activity in order to get work done
so each party in this dialogue this
conversation each victim
essentially has a track of the
conversation
although they may have a track basically
as you know I sent this request I
received this request I sent this reply
I received this reply
but they're essentially tracking a
conversation and both sides effectively
have a copy of it
it may be the what happens is we have
quite a lot of fiefdoms involved
so in this case fiefdom a says hey you
know I need to basically get
um some uh discounts for your order as
an example
to make sure I've actually applied the
discount so it calls basically another
feastum that deals with promotions and
that one says uh yeah well effectively
in order to figure out all the
promotions I have to figure out whether
this customer is on our
loyalty program or our subscription
program so I'm going to call this other
fiefdom that deals with that and ask it
a question and say hey is this basically
a customer on that program it gives me a
response back I then can basically
update my calculation and then I reply
back to the initial item
initial caller so these things move
across a number of
fiefdoms
and so an activity can essentially
initiate a new collaboration which is in
other words to say rather than just
simply the work I received I'm executing
it and calling one other fiefdom that
requires an uh responds to me what I'm
kicking off is actually if you're like a
sub workflow that will complete and then
come back to me and then I can resume my
workflow
okay
so each one of those workflows is what
we think of as a collaboration
and it may be that you kick off a sub
workflow in order that has to complete
before you can complete uh yourself
typically
we need a correlation ID which
essentially mentioned with name right if
I'm sending out requests and I'm getting
responses back and they're coming in
effectively asynchronously I need to
match them up and say oh okay this is a
response on the payment request for this
order this is response on discounts or
delivery fees for this order essentially
I go and retrieve that from the database
up data according to the response that
I've received and move my workflow on
right
we may also want to record some kind of
conversation ID
the conversation ID will tell us there's
a part of a larger collaboration
you know
about the flow this particular message
exchange which other fiefdom by
correlation ID but actually you are just
one Exchange in part of a larger
workflow which is with basically this
conversational dialogue we're having
which we also want an ID for and that
means we can track and figure out what
the hell is going on at times right
okay
often
that conversation may have a natural ID
that makes sense the order ID for
example may actually be useful as the
conversation ID that tells you what is
happening
so these collaborations
represent at least one request reply but
probably more
okay and it's this workflow that
represents all of the interactions
between fiefdoms we need to do to get
work done
so we can think about the idea that this
activity provides orchestration so if
you've heard the terms orchestration and
choreography orchestration is when
essentially we arrange something and
there is somebody in charge they are
directing the flow and choreography is
when there's no one really in charge
it's just the interactions we tend to
often say oh we prefer orchestration to
choreography because if I put somebody
in charge that causes a problem for me
because I am I'm now coupled on my
services to this person in charge and
essentially I can't really change
anything and quite often we worry that I
end up with what's called an entity
service because all of my natural
business logic moves into this
coordinator
and doesn't actually remain in the
actual domain based micro services or
food terms in our case
but what we're doing here is slightly
different right the fiefdoms just
orchestrating its individual interaction
with one other partner it's not
orchestrating all interactions
and it leaves basically not externally
but within the service that owns that
interaction the thing that got kicked
off that says hey I'm the process orders
fiefdom I do processing of orders I
understand the domain of what needs to
be done to process an order
I hold that logic not an external
process manager coordinator or something
else
and that means I don't violate say the
micro Services rule of smart endpoints
and downpipes right the smart the
business logic still lives within my
service I haven't externalized it to
some kind of coordinator which says I am
running the workflow
my individual fiefdom knows how to run
its portion of an overall collaboration
because it knows who it has to interact
with right and each side in that in that
dialogue interaction has a record of the
of the of the interaction through the
messages that flow through it
choreography exists here in how all of
these individual conversations these
orchestrations fit together to form a
collaboration
so we still essentially get a lot of
that loose coupling that choreography
offers us
but we couple it with the ability for
individual feastum to orchestrate their
reaction its interaction with a partner
so there's a dichotomy between
orchestration and choreography where we
think about having a orchestrator as
this externalized service is a bit of a
false dichotomy for Pat because really
what he's suggesting is that
orchestration is something that an
individual fiefdom does in order to
interact with other fiefdoms
and it's important to try and think
about why we want to do this often
we have causality in a workflow that's
cause and effect right
in order to essentially take this order
that you've given me and move it to
fulfillment so it gets shipped from the
warehouse cooked in the kitchen whatever
your your domain is
I need to make sure that I've taken a
payment
so I have cause and effect right in the
sense that I have from my point of view
of process orders before I move to the
Fulfillment step of raising a message to
say to fulfillment hey fulfillment you
can get on with this now
right
I need to have called the piece that
says hey I'm going to process the
payment or I'm going to calculate the
discount so I'm going to calculate the
delivery fees there is a sequence in
which stuff needs to be done
okay
and so by by orchestrating those Steps
From Within my own fiefdom
I can make sure that causality is
applied and there's I don't talk about
it there's nothing on the slide here but
there's a problem space we refer to as
an event chain where people essentially
throw away cause and effect and just say
I'm only going to raise events I'm never
going to send a command
and the problem is we don't know what
sequence things are happening anymore
right and sometimes it works and then
you scale up effectively and discover
wow I got timing issues all over the
shop and I've got things happening out
of order
so this orchestration preserves cause
and effect for us
and the activity can manage unhappy
paths too
so if effectively someone says hey that
payment was declined or we couldn't
calculate basically the offer or that
person has been banned as a customer uh
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
offering them any service that response
comes back then the process orders fifth
term 50 may it simply says great I know
what to do with that just another flow
right
to this state machine that you're
running essentially in the fiefdom is
able to react to failures and then do
other work so maybe it causes an
entirely different Freedom that says hey
I need to talk to you because there are
failures and other interactions
so fifteen's might for example want to
perform tentative operations this is
very similar to what we want we saw in
TPC
where essentially I say hey you're
purchasing a ticket or you're buying
some stock or whatever and that
transaction might fall through there
might be no payment the customer might
have bought before the end so what I
want you to do for me is I want to
basically Reserve that particular
resource
right so so did other Freedom how can
you reserve Reserve that resource for me
I think someone says fine that's yours
and quite often gives me a time figure
yeah that's yours for 10 minutes 10
minutes time I don't hear back from you
I will effectively abort basically
holding the reservation
you then do your work and essentially at
some point you say hey it's fine that's
great I want that stock or
you say hey I don't want that at all can
we have bought that operation
and you can see essentially you're doing
something very similar to what TPC does
but I'm just doing it from application
code running in my feed term I have some
kind of estate machine I'm application
code and essentially what I say is hey
I'm just going to send a message asking
you to reserve I get a response back
that's great I go on with my workflow
hey I'm going to commit that I want to
basically purchase those tickets or buy
that stock
so while this looks a lot like TPC
and it also looks a lot for those of you
familiar with it something like The Saga
pattern it's important to recognize one
of the big differences is there's no
Central coordinator
application code running in the freedom
is all that manages by the flow of
messages
what we need to do in order to make the
whole collaboration work
okay
let's talk a little bit about uh let's
just type so this stuff is not from Pat
this comes uh from Clements vasters um
but it's useful to the conversation to
to have to try it in here
so people like Clements have been
talking about this difference between
what they see as messaging and Eventing
there is some argument about the terms
uh but just to understand basically what
they mean
messaging has intent please buy me a
coffee
uh events basically provide facts I'm
thirsty
but we're passive aggressive events I
would really like a coffee which is sent
to one person with the expressive
intention that they would get you a
coffee that is basically a command you
are fooling yourself it's basically what
we call a passive aggressive event
and I'm British so you know uh all right
so messages can do things that request
an answer they can transfer control
which is the kind of thing we've just
been seeing I send you a command please
carry out some instruction for me and
let me know when it's done
um they can transfer value hey I
finished working on this it's yours now
you do whatever you need right
and generally messaging is part of a
work for our conversation there is
usually a dialogue involved here
sometimes we do far and forget we
essentially say hey I'm giving you an
instruction you know what I'm not giving
you the right to refuse
um I expect you to just basically do it
and maybe we'll just deal with any
problems out of band right customer will
phone up and complain right
um
by contrast events tend to be no
expectations they're historical they
represent state that happened in that
fiefdom I'm notifying you about it but
there are usually zero or more receivers
zero or more is important right I don't
know whether anyone's actually going to
do anything with the fact that I'm
thirsty maybe they'll bring me water
maybe they'll bring me a coffee maybe
I'll get lucky but I'm not have I don't
have an expectation out there a lot of
what I'm basically shipping to you is
something happened here often executed a
command it may be of interest to you and
you may want to deal with that it's how
we build data lakes and it's how we
build reference data which we'll come to
in a second
okay it's a monologue usually right not
a dialogue you are simply saying here is
some information I am not entering into
discussion with you about it
and messaging is the future
and Eventing is the past
so messaging says I propose the world
looks like this to somebody else all
right or can you make the world look
like this can you take a payment for me
right can you apply discounts
can you play offers
only a fiefdom has a notion of now for
things that are owns
as soon as data leaves the feast and it
becomes effectively style right because
essentially it can only represent what
we what it knew at the time that it gave
you a response or issued an event
so if we want to update something and
say hey future future people
what does this look like I have to send
it basically to another fiefdom and say
please update it based on your context
of now and tell me what happened
so jobs work that kind of thing where I
have an expectation that you do it tend
to be done by commands
and it's these that you see a lot of
activities dealing with
events are past States you want to get a
response back
it will be an event of some sort right
because it represents past State hey I I
a payment was made that happened
it's not happening now right
and we have to be aware of that past
date because essentially sometimes it
may no longer be accurate right here is
that but here is basically the customers
address in case you need it in the
future but the customer may have gone
and updated that just moments after I
gave you that information you're hoping
I will send you another event later
which will update you so that you can
catch up
and so when I receive a reply is one of
these basically activities it's
generally an event I'm receiving
events tend to come in two forms series
and discrete so discrete ones say oh hey
you know what here's an event
um I'm sending it to you you didn't
really ask me for it um please can you
react to it
and Sarah's events basically say uh hey
I'd like to ask you for information
about this so it's How We Do queries
instead of doing get right
discrete continuous discrete basically
effectively there's just one of them you
take you handle that you're not looking
for others continuous I'm subscribed to
it and it will keep sending me more
updates it's syndicated
independent in other words for actually
I deal with this one doesn't burn any
relation to the others this replies that
reply to that request to the request of
like a payment it's not reply to other
requests it's not related to other
requests to make payment
sequential uh this represents some data
like uh changes to a customer account
and you'll want to keep listening to it
because you want to get all the changes
and they're related to each other
immediately actionable generally you
receive a reply and you expect to do
something right hey the payment was
updated I'm going to advance the
workflow
um or the fear is basically conditional
context so it's saying hey this is the
state right now the customer you may
need that information in the future
and discrete is part of the conversation
it's a reply usually and Sarah is
effectively as part of a monologue it's
essentially that service telling me
stuff
um but
uh it's not expecting a reply or
response from me
so to go back to sort of a reference
data that we were looking at earlier
reference data is when essentially I say
here are some facts about the data I
hold you may want in the future
you may want to have the product catalog
so that you can make orders right we
ship you with menus we do that by
effectively publishing putting an S3
buck in publishing and cloudfront so you
can pick them up from your web app or
your phone
so that you can effectively then the
customers can make orders right you
don't do a get and ask us for it we
publish it to you ahead of time
right and reference data is a really
important part of how we tend to scale
in event driven architectures it says
don't do gets to other services because
that introduces temporal coupling and
synchronous conversations
subscribe to a stream of data from them
which you can store locally and you just
look up in your local
forward cache of that data
when you need it so you don't do gets
anymore right
this is all part of this idea of your
data living inside your fiefdom is not
available to me but outside data is
available to me
okay
all right this is basically a monologue
got some Pat sometimes calls it a
syndication right uh his example
effectively is the old school you know
Sears catalog that would drop for three
people's letterboxes and then they could
effectively make orders from them that's
actually what this reference data is
the point all right uh emissaries
emissaries are essentially the way we
interact with fief terms and the simple
way of thinking about emissaries is
basically a UI though it could be an SDK
typically this is the way you begin to
realize that a future as well as being a
microservice could also be basically a
user agent or a phone app right
and essentially quite often it's using
the reference data to make selections
and from those selections it makes
requests basically to the victim for
action
Christians don't trust our emissaries
they validate the data that comes
through them
the way to think about this often best
in order to basically make this work
system is to conceptually believe that
your Emissary is always offline
and by that we mean
you should provide your membership the
data it needs to do its work and when
effectively at the end you need to
basically have action from the fiefdom
you hit kind of a button and you send it
to the back end you cue it for being
sent to the back end
so even when you're for example taking
an order from a customer on an
e-commerce site you give them all the
data they need to basically build up the
order or the product catalog information
or the data they need they build up the
order and the point where effectively
they hit the button you can pretend kind
of up to then you're all offline and
essentially that's the only point you
need to communicate when you effectively
then say I'm going to send something to
the back end
to actually get work done
all right
so we said hey we don't use synchross
communication between these victims
we use messaging
so it's important thing to understand is
that if I send a message
to represent some change in state I've
updated my local activity and I now have
said basically we are now in the payment
pending status it would imply that I've
also sent uh a message which says hey
please can you take the payment
and the problem is if I live in a world
without two-phase commit and that's
quite likely that with between a
database and say a message broker I
wouldn't have a coordinator because they
come from different vendors anyway
there's a real danger that essentially I
would update basically the data and move
it to payment pending but the message
doesn't get sent
so it's important when we do this to
have transactional messaging by which we
mean that the message must be guaranteed
to be sent if we change the state
locally
a typical way to do that is called the
outbox pattern
so in the outbox plan what we do is we
create a we create another table that
basically says hey we're going to set
the messages in here that we're going to
send
and then in a transaction
we can right basically a transaction
that both insert makes the change to our
activity to look we're clearing out what
resources are related but Resource as
well right
and at the same time create the message
that goes alongside them
and then we simply pull the outbox table
by a worker process or thread for
anything that hasn't been sent yet and
we send it
and then we mark it Ascent when the
broker tells us it's it's done all right
and that effectively means that we
guarantee
that our message is that are outgoing
represent our internal State and in a
sense this is basically part of what
activity is doing it's recording
outgoing messages
we don't know
whether or not effectively the failure
for a broker to acknowledge
that the message was sent comes because
it didn't actually send the message or
which we didn't receive the
acknowledgment we can't ever really know
that it could just be a network
connection
failure on the response it could be that
the broker effectively just timed out
doing it but effectively in the end
replicates it all around its cluster and
the asynchronous response we get
um uh does it says it failed but we
already succeeded and so the risk there
are effectively is that we end up
because we don't Mark basically that
item as sent in our message box from our
worker thread or process sending it
twice
right you didn't respond to me to say
the message was sent within a certain
time frame effectively I look at my
track of unsent messages and I say well
this message has been sitting and
sitting here in my outbox table marked
as unseen for too long I better resend
it
it may be that eventually the broker is
going to respond and tell me yeah it was
sent but I can't take that risk I need
to resend it because I've got timing of
the whole operation at stake here
and that means I you should expect
duplicates
and because you should expect duplicates
you need to have some way of saying I
need to I need to deal with that problem
now you could just be item potent
in which case effectively reapplying
that change doesn't matter and that's
more typical with events with commands
that are requests for work it's often
difficult to do it twice so we create a
thing called an inbox
and we say I'm going to recall all the
messages I've received
and then I'll just look up and see
whether I've received that message
already
and if I have I don't need to action it
so remember activities not only do
messages we have sent but they also do
messages we receive
the other alternative is out in potents
right they're a notion substantive side
effects you can just ignore the fact
that you do the the inbox so sometimes
for example if I receive a reply saying
payment was made for an order I don't
necessarily need to worry about by
checking that in a inbox because if I
reapply the order was paid for
well the order was still paid for
we may also need
to reissue our response if we get a
repeat message
we get something comes into our inbox
says can you do this again
we don't necessarily know whether that
might be a deliberate resend because
something downstreaming from us has
failed so we quite often had to have the
capability in our inbox to say actually
you know what you should resend the
message that you had before
typically if you have an outbox you can
just clear the published value on the
outbox and then it'll just get reset
and it has to be effectively the same
response we created earlier so the
outbox helps you out there right
so the outbox pattern depends upon you
being able to have a transaction in your
database
what happens if you can't have a
transaction in your database because you
don't have you know using a document
store or something that doesn't support
transactions across multiple multiple
tables or multiple documents
a couple other options first option is
log tailing typically your database May
expose effectively rights as a stream
you listen to that stream when you see a
write you take the action of creating
the appropriate outgoing message write
that to the outbox and then your worker
process just reads the outbox from there
right so it's kind of an extra step
where effectively you're saying because
they can't have transactions I'll rely
on being able to read the stream in
order and then I'll just write the
corresponding message to the outbox and
then that will get sent a little more
delay but it works without transactions
the other option you have is basically
to send the message and listen to your
own message and update your state when
you see your own outgoing message
right it's simple it's effective the
only slight thing is timing right if
somebody else wants to ask you what the
state is you may disagree with somebody
else Downstream it's purchase the
message before you have
to just be worried about timing issues
if you choose that option
so our overall model inside some kind of
fiefdom looks a bit like this I've got
this some kind of collaboration I'm
participating in the collaboration
doesn't exist as anything probably more
than IDs for a conversation or natural
IDs that I'm attaching to messages it
may also exist in some kind of uh span
that I'm putting into my uh telemetry
and I am receiving messages into my fief
term some of them are initiating work
some of them are during basically the
process of some initiate collaboration
some of them are steps in a
collaboration
and that runs application code remember
Pat's point is it's application code
that has to deal with uncertainty in the
absence of basic TPC
and it will effectively update a couple
of things what pack calls resources
those are abstractions over things
right
and activities which essentially are
Notions of State uh and the state
basically that are given activity that
you own which is a portion of a workflow
is in
there are multiple ways to implement
this as Pat points out its application
code so there are lots of options for us
right things like Aggregates obviously
if you know DDD have a strong affinity
for this because they are essentially
State machines over some resources but
you could even use a a workflow engine
inside your feed term right you could
just have a notion of activity and a
resource as being quite explicit
Concepts in your domain there is not
effectively a prescribed way of doing
this the important thing to understand
is that you have individual fiefdoms
that have activities that have code and
some state that run their portion of a
collaboration and you don't have a
centralized controller running it
all right so we'll briefly look up
brighter so brighter is an open source
project that I work on
it's for.net developers there are
equivalents I think like
um uh you know uh mass transit and
service bus Rebus in our space outside
our space if you're a JavaScript
developer I recommend I'm going to look
at Seneca if you're if you're a Java
developer you're probably just embredded
in spring anyway so what does it matter
um uh but there are various Alternatives
right we'll just show you how this one
works so you get a feel for it so this
uh hideous diagram represents basically
how brighter Works in terms of receiving
messages there's a dispatcher at the top
that's basically a supervisor worker
that says hey I'm going to spin up some
threads and something needs to own them
all
for any given subscription to messages
so someone who's saying hey any messages
basically on this topic or this routine
key I want those we have a consumer
and a consumer can spin up any number of
threads and we call them the performer
which essentially will process messages
from that given subscription so if it's
a queue from that given queue if it's a
stream effectively from that given
stream generally if it's a stream like
Kafka you only want one performer but
you can do competing consumers and
multiple performance right
and each performer has a message pump
and the message pump says my job is to
go and read from the message queue
and I get a message off the queue
right and I turn what is the Json or
Avro or
um Pro a protobuf body into something
you can recognize in code so type in
your type system
let me give it a topical command
processor and that says okay find some
code that handles this message
and it runs a middleware pipeline
and that middleware pipeline does a
number of things they're optional so one
of them we do is an inbox which says
have I seen this message already
if I have I don't know how to process it
other one is basically for net devs is
poly we basically offer you resilience
there you're not a.net Dev that's just
stuff that does retries and circuit
breakers
and you can add your own middleware into
brighter basically to do steps that you
want right and then finally you've got
your artwork your request Handler that
runs your domain code
this portion is essentially what an
activity does
there's an inbox to check for stuff
there are some domain code that you can
run
we also offer you an outbox
so when your request Handler
wants to basically write an outgoing
message at the same time as updating
resources that it owns
we can get our outbox to participate in
that transaction
such that effectively we will write
messages to our outbox at the same time
as you update your resources and we also
offer you a sweeper thread which we'll
go through and look in your outbox for
things that haven't been sent and try
and dispatch them to your broker
okay
what does it look like
um this is the only bit probably for the
the net developers the rest of you can
kind of just glise over if you like
um so we basically use attributes for
middleware Pipeline and this one is
saying hey I need an inbox I want to
de-duplicate stuff I don't want to
basically try on a line item potency
here
then we have a Handler so if you're
dealing with Thief terms that do with
messaging and activities and a lot of
cases what happens you have this kind of
model where you have a Handler that says
I am reacting
to being sent a message
I am doing I am either initiating
basically my part of a collaboration my
activity or effectively I am responding
to a reply as part of it with Sarah Paul
in a second
let me begin a transaction we support a
number of
um common tools in the.net space Entity
framework core this is Dapper we're
using here so we begin a transaction
explicitly because we want to
participate as part of that transaction
in order to write to the outbox
then you'll probably in this example
we're using some kind of aggregate-based
approach so the aggregate contains a
state machine and can take our order
through the various States involved
so here we go to a factory and say well
we're creating a new one it's the
initiation of a collaboration so we use
a factory and we create our new order
and we check basically from the checkout
information we've received as a message
that wants to initiate the order process
so I forgot to mention that we've
listened to a checkout event so we want
to create the order based on the
customers check out we're going to
process it and take payments for it and
stuff like that
um we want to validate it's correct and
then we'll save it in the database
and then we create basically a message
for payment
we're not done on process order until
basically at least we've got it paid for
well then we'll hand it to fulfillment
right
so we create an outgoing message and we
say we want to take a payment for this
and we write it to post box so postbox
is just not a command processor it's
just a local name in this code for it
right and we say put it in there so but
the post box notion is just basically
hey here's someone want to store
something
and then we've got to commit the
transaction
and your new order exists in our data
table along with the request to pay for
it or we bought the transaction and
neither happens right
so later on in the same collaboration
well the same activity for us we might
receive a response
back from the payment system again
there's an inbox in case you've seen it
before we may we might have been okay
with not having an inbox in this case
um because you know payment is payment
but we do ship to fulfillment later so
probably we might want to do that twice
twice
um we listen to the payment request
right this Handler gets kicked off when
a payment request comes in it just runs
your Handler code
we look at the payment request and we
say
let's begin a transaction
let's find essentially the order this
payment relates to the correlation ID is
going to just be the order ID that's
what we're using we can use the natural
one this is just some Dapper code for
those that don't know.net I haven't seen
it and it's saying Go away and find me
the order that matches this order ID I
want to get it out and then I'm going to
call a method on it to essentially
Advance its state by telling that
payment's been made
and then I pass in the payment details
to it so it can update whatever it needs
to update locally presumably the order
resource
and then I want to hand this work on to
the next step and actually usually
perform with different Feast them so I'm
going to send it a message to bring
begin a collaboration for fiefdom
to do that work so I create a
fulfillment request and I put a message
in my outbox saying hey go and do the
work by seeing order to fulfill this
right and then again I commit or robot
the transaction
none of this has required me
to build an external Saga process
manager coordinator
just so you know this is kind of how you
configure brighter such that you would
get uh an outbox we support a range of
databases effectively what you're doing
is saying Hey I want to use this type of
outbox and here's some configuration
information for it
this line says hey you should use we
need to share these transactions
when you're writing basically to the
outbox
and this line says I want to use a
sweeper so I want you to basically spin
up a thread they'll monitor the outbox
and send messages basically that haven't
been sent yet sometimes
you don't want to wait for the sweeper
to run you don't want that kind of delay
and you just want to say I'm going to
try first of all to send it immediately
let's see if we're just going to
basically try and send stuff that didn't
work
and that's okay
what you can do effectively is create a
list of posts add your post effectively
into the list of posts and you can
explicitly just clear it all at the end
of your Handler
so
just to kind of summarize
Pat's argument is that application code
is what you use in distributed
applications when you want to replace
TPC not something like a saga or process
manager Etc now the application code
that does that orchestration runs and
each individual fiefdom 50 could be a
micro service but it might also be code
running basically on a phone or a user
agent or a browser
and what we do is essentially write
activities and activities effectively
are code that handles the workflow
portion that I need in response to a
message and it may pause because it
starts its own collaboration saying hey
go and do this other work for me and
receives a response back and wakes up we
wake up the state for it and then resume
it right and the combination of all
these activities running which is
eventually choreography form is a
collaboration we can use
okay
don't need to use PC TPC don't use a
coordinator or a saga and your code
to do that is something like this
all right
some kind of Handler with some
middleware to deal with things like
outboxes and inboxes Etc that you need
all right
that's that talk
it's traditional to put the green ticket
in the box outside when you go thank you
very much